Kevin Hart here.
Paterson, New Jersey.
Of course I'm not by myself,
I'm with some funny, funny
gentlemen.
Ty Raney, Cee Jay Craxx, Kendall
"Shorty" Ward, and Rey Gibbs.
How would you guys describe
your style of comedy?
It's more personable.
It's about myself
and my experiences.
Like coming from a--
I don't want to say a
little dude's perspective.
OK.
But, uh, why you
look at me like that?
Why'd you say "little dude"
then make eye contact with me?
I don't-- I consider
myself a very large male.
Does the family
support your craft?
Are they all about the
movement, the comedy movement?
Naw.
No, I mean, my--
[kevin laughing]
They supported me
more when I sold drugs.
They don't--
[all laughing]
--no, they don't believe in me.
They don't even believe
this is going on.
My girl wants me to get a
job soon as this is over,
soon as we get back.
She got Home Depot
apps on the bed.
Nah, they don't believe.
Do y'all feel like comedy
is more sensitive today than
what it was back in the day?
I mean, for the most part,
being younger in the game,
I think sometimes you want
to make sure you ain't
doing the wrong thing or step on
any toes or anything like that.
Sometimes you get
rules and regulations
when you get to a show.
So a lot of times it just
helps you adapt, you know?
Biggest bomb moment.
Worst show ever, that's what
I want to know right now.
- I do prison tours as well--
- Whoa.
--in Pennsylvania.
Yeah.
The inmates are there,
they're chilling.
There's nothing
separating us from them,
it's just bleachers,
the floor, and me.
I've done one.
So long story short, I
wasn't getting to the funny,
or the punch of my jokes.
And there was this
one brother that
was just sitting in the front.
He had this long
goatee and he was
just staring at me like this.
And I was like, all
right, I'm not getting
any reaction from anybody.
I just looked at him, I
was like, brother do you
want me to get off the stage?
He just rubbed his chin,
he said, "absolutely."
[all laughing]
I said, that's my time.
I'm Ty Raney.
I'll see you all next time.
That was it.